[Music]
the latest trailer speaks for itself
Godzilla will fight the Iron Dragon in
Monarch in the legacy of monsters and no
it won't be the small Iron Dragon that
was seen in the second episode this one
is more massive and definitely a Titan
siiz creature so let's dive into the
profile or description of this new Titan
and how much in size it will be in the
modern time frame as compared to its
1952 first appearance then talk a bit
about Godzilla's growth and change in
the series and lastly conclude with why
it might be the main enemy and how its
fight with Godzilla would change
everything here let's get to it the Iron
Dragon was seen as a colossal flying
creature spawning a black coloration
with scales that are smooth and seems to
have small bumps all over the body with
also massive membranous Wings
reminiscent of bat wings
drawing inspiration from the Flying Fish
its wings resemble Frills while the
Fearsome Jaws resemble a terrifying
angler fish it bows a head adorned with
two large Buffalo sized horns and its
jaws combine needle-like teeth with a
hooked beak the monster has several
spikes on its back and it is equipped
with two legs with deadly Talons and a
long tail that concludes with a f design
it seems to be 9 M tall or 30 ft and 150
ft or 45 M long which makes it the size
of a Game of Thrones dragon but that is
in
1952 so as we saw in the trailer this
creature is definitely more massive and
definitely the big bad of the series in
the final scene of the teaser if you can
pause its head is as big as Godzilla's
head and therefore with its horn it
makes it even look more intimidating so
Godzilla here in this scene has already
evolved from the 1954 to the 2014
version and finally to the 2019 form
which puts him him at roughly 120 M or
393 ft in height thus the Iron Dragon
here even though it has a smaller body
type is still big as I would
roughly estimate it to be 200 to 250 ft
in height that would make it bigger than
Rodan bigger than Mothra and even bigger
than gamot maybe the biggest flying
Titan outside of Monster Zero and the
warb bats and its wingspan would
definitely be in the 700 to 800 ft or
210 to 240 M range in the prise range of
Mothra and Rodan so the Iron Dragon
lives up to its name showcasing
impressive flight with its massive
membranous wings that releases
radioactive irons creating mesmerizing
Aurora likee patterns in the sky this
creature was also seen in glimpses in
the intro over the Skies of Tokyo and
San Francisco which tells us that it
might be the main enemy Titan of
Godzilla and humans in the series well
at least for the first season the
creatures formidable claw as a juvenile
in 1952 possessed the strength to
effortlessly tear through the USS lon's
Hull which is completely metal so
imagine it as an adult specimen it would
definitely have the power to cause
Grievous injuries to even the Big G so
this will be interesting I admit that
the first few episodes had us in a state
of anger in showing small animals as
Titans but yeah now when I see the giant
sides adult specimens the Iron Dragon
I'm pretty sure this show will smash
records in and out so the last question
is what is the mystery about it and the
USS Len and did it really drag the ship
Inland well now the Iron Dragon as we
have seen it seeing its size as an adult
and being an aerial Muto would be the
culprit and is absolutely capable of
destroying the ship and carrying it
Inland we said before in an earlier
video that maybe another large Titan
took it from the Seas and for some
reason uh dragged it Inland and then
later the smaller Iron Dragon claimed it
for its own well we were partly right we
also said that maybe there is a bigger
specimen that dragged the ship Inland
for a female to lay its eggs in so that
was also partly right right we are now
sure that it was an adult Iron Dragon
that caused a lot an incident and that
maybe it got killed by the Big G in the
1950s and now the juvenile from the
Philippines would have grown up and will
take revenge on Godzilla for killing its
parent or it's just a natural enemy
Titan species like the mutos and it's
causing Havoc so Godzilla will have to
fight it so you know in fact all this
ties together the main plot of the show
with the largest Cinematic Universe the
monsterverse and it does pretty well you
know as it was stated in the synopsis
Lea had information about a world-
ending threat you know this might mean
the Iron Dragon and it was trying to
awaken the Titans therefore giving scope
for Monarch to later discover new Titans
hibernating worldwide it would also give
the idea of waking up the Titans to Emma
Russell and Alan Jonah in kotm and then
this will also finally put a rest to the
laen incident the Len problem so if you
like this video then check this other
one as well and also check out our
Channel we might just have things that
you haven't seen before like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care fam